Janet Jackson and husband we saw al mana  have split I thought it was important  that you be the first to know the 50  year old singer has called it quits with  her husband of five years a source  confirmed the news to ET on Sunday the  news comes just three months after the  pop icon gave birth to the couple's  first child together a son aissa al mana  my husband and I are planning our family  so I'm gonna have to delay the tour  janet posted that video to her youtube  account last April amid her first major  tour in years and ET was first to break  the news of her pregnancy a month later  no word on the reasoning behind the  couple split but sources told The Mail  on Sunday quote it's amicable and ice ax  will stay with his mother who is basing  herself in London et has reached out to  the couple's rep for comment  [Music]